uh this is how minnesota came out four
years ago hillary clinton a narrow win a
lot of people forget about this just
forty four thousand votes in 2016.
i mentioned michigan a moment ago when a
uh jump back here
because this was a state that was
decided by 11 000 votes trump
beating hillary clinton and the
wolverine state i mentioned detroit down
here want to go to dearborn michigan
right now
from the biden campaign democratic
congresswoman debbie dingle is with me
now and
good afternoon to you here we are four
years later
i want to remind you and our viewers at
home that you came on the air with me in
2016 and said
i think trump can win this thing what do
you think now
i hi bill it's good to see you bad day
for those of us who cheered for michigan
but
you know we'll keep going it's going to
be a go blue day on tuesday that's my
prediction
but i i do say i agree with him on one
thing i just listened to i don't believe
the polls
the only poll that matters is the poll
on election day people have to go vote
and this is coming down to voter turnout
voter turnout voter turnout
i think a lot of people didn't believe
that donald trump could win a lot of
people in michigan left that 90
000 people left the top of their ticket
uh blank last time
uh and you don't feel that but i do feel
in certain parts of the states with
certain demographics it's tightening
uh the reason that joe biden and
president obama are here
in flint and detroit is we need to get
the people out
in those cities you can't take them for
granted and women
are turning out in massive numbers much
more so
than they did uh four years ago some of
this anecdotal evidence coming out of
the southeast especially in florida how
much concern do you have about the
reports about hispanic votes going for
trump
and african support being soft
african-american support being saw
look i don't take anything for granted i
am not one of these cheerleaders that
says
you know this is a dumb election it's
not going to be done
every person that hasn't voted their
care strongly
needs to go out and vote i think
momentum is with joe biden right now
i think covet i do agree that covet is
going to be
an issue that people are going to vote
on but i do think that it's turned
people's worlds upside down
today in michigan we had the highest
number yet it's surging in states across
the country
uh and people are scared they're scared
about their jobs they're scared about
what's going to happen to it
a simple if the president had chosen to
wear a mask
in many places he would have because
people listen to him
because people follow him he would
reduce the number of people
got this and would have reduced the
deaths that when he comes
into michigan you got to go no it's okay
i got a minute left i i know the point
you're driving out there and we're going
to see on wednesday
what the state of covet is um on on
behalf of both men
final point here though what we hear
from republicans consistently is that
they go on these battleground states
they see no ground game for joe biden
how do you feel about that
well we do have a ground game now uh you
know there's been a ton
millions of calls and you know that i
think we got to figure out how we're
gonna
measure that at some point but i can
tell you i've had a ground game in the
12th district i have 49
000 people that have already returned
their av ballots and did not vote in
2016 41 000 of them are likely democrats
we are doing doors and our targeted
state legislative seats
have been doing doors since july so the
biden campaign has now started doing
paid canvasses we're in all of the
targeted precincts
we do have a down ground game and we're
going to deliver on do you want to give
us a prediction
three days out congresswoman what
happens can i give you a prediction on
monday
i'm out there listening to people i do
think joe biden's likely to win but it's
going to be tighter than people think
right now thank you for your time we'll
find out together maybe we'll talk on
monday okay debbie dingle thank you
back home in detroit michigan